hey everyone so enough happened I feel
like since the last vlog that I can
legitimately do another one
I've actually filmed this a little way
in advance because right now I am home
for Easter it's the first time in my
life since I was I guess four where I
haven't had set holidays for you know
when you work up until this day and then
you have two weeks off now I'm a PhD
student I just work year-round and I am
basically entitled to manage my time
however I want provide that I get the
work done so I think up until now I
haven't legitimate allowed myself a
break apart from a couple of days of
Christmas so I am currently back home in
Bristol
hopefully relaxing but probably still
working and I am about to leave tomorrow
so where am I gonna put this out I don't
even know I really hope that something
massive hasn't happened in the
intervening time between me filming this
and this going live because we really
awkward if you know x2 is blown off the
map by some massive explosion especially
be even more awkward now that I just
said that if then it were to happen I
would immediately be on a police
blacklist sorry okay let's just hope
that everything's still here when I get
back I guess it's almost the defining
moment in becoming an adult in that you
start to manage your own time rather
than having it explicitly mapped out for
you I I find becoming an adult very
scary the whole idea that I am 23 and
turning 24 soon what as I sued a couple
of months is really scary because when I
was in school I thought the 23 and 24
year olds had it all figured out and the
you know you know what you were doing in
life and I feel like at this age I'm
about as clueless now as I was then
although having said that my best mate
John he might remember from my ball
video came up and visited an Dexter and
it's kind of like we are not accepting
mutually that we are adults yet so we
did a few food challenges like the coke
and mentos challenge and the fluffy
bunny challenge
Cina I'm an adult not an adult with a
capital A not just yet so one of the
things which I talked about in my last
vlog was the Iowan going to Vienna for
this conference the eg you and I now
have my personal program ah there we go
so um eg you as I mentioned before is
this massive conference which is of
course all the sciences in Europe and
anybody is free to go who's at the
company had to pay to get into the
conference anybody who's paid that can
go to any of the talks so whilst my
research is on atmospheric physics and
specifically on stratosphere topics for
coupling I can go to any session I want
to and that can be soil management it
can be stuff to do with space
exploration it can be pretty much
anything you can think of this to do
with physical science relating to either
this planet or another planet or even
planets you know around other stars so
this is kind of like my dream when I was
a kid because apart from my research I'm
also going to for example outer planets
icy satellites and rings and then
immediately after that turbulence in the
atmosphere and oceanic boundary layers
polar ozone and there's another one I'm
going to unlike Rovers on Mars there's
another one in meteorology there's a few
really interesting looking ones on
science communication because I think
well one of the big issues in modern
science is communicating the value of
your research to a broader public
because it's all well and good doing
science and increasing the wealth of
knowledge that a few people have
available to them you know science
should be done for the benefit of
everybody science is a universal thing
so communicating your research and why
it's so interesting and the basic ideas
of what you're doing is so so important
and there's there's a quite a few
sessions that they've organized both in
terms of video communication as long as
called scientist must film which I like
to think is probably to be hosted by
Tarzan and there's a few other ones
about interactive science demonstrations
but there are also going back to my
research two big sessions that
specifically on what I am looking at now
I'm hoping that I am going to be able to
film one or two videos about the
experience I'm going with another PhD
student from Exeter and we're going to
bumble our way around for a week in
Vienna so I'm sure there's going to be
plenty of stuff to film so
hopefully you'll be coming with me
lastly the thing which we talked about
last time I say we talked about I talk
with the camera and you commented in the
last vlog was the nature of
subscriptions and what causes people to
subscribe to a set channel I read
through all the comments I read every
single one and I think that the themes
which kept coming up were videos which
are educational or interesting which
have themes which are parallel to your
interests and what came up a lot was the
personality of the person who presents
the content and I think the person which
really nailed it was Monty 9:46 great
profile picture by the way who basically
compared the nature of YouTube
subscriptions to subscribing to a hobby
magazine and I think I hadn't thought of
it like that and it is exactly what it
is actually picking something
publication in the world of pre-internet
and now a YouTube channel which
symbolizes themes which are interested
in you know if you're interested in
running you get a subscription to
running world magazine but there's a
difference and I think that what makes
it interesting in the digital age is
that it's almost like your interests
aren't manifested as the presenter so
it's not enough that the content is
interesting because that is what a lot
of people said that it is just the
content interests them I don't think
that is necessarily true I think that
your interests are manifested in the
presenter and so you must personally
find the presenter engaging which raises
another interesting question the people
why do people make each of you is
because essentially we are making
ourselves into a commodity we are the
people and I say wait I mean the people
that make videos like myself like philip
defranco like Charlie McDonnell you know
we are putting ourselves on camera and
saying look I represent certain things
and do you find that interesting because
if you do you should stick around and
our videos in a way represent a magazine
where we write every article but more
than that we are the article if that
makes sense and I think in many ways
YouTube represents kind of a return to
the old oral tradition this idea that
people would come and listen to people
telling stories there be storytellers
that would roam
and they'll make a living telling
stories that's essentially what YouTube
is YouTube is the world campfire where
you can come and sit and listen to
people and you can toast marshmallows
over your computer if it's actually if
you can do that you should probably
invest in a cooling system or something
and I suppose that first up yet another
question which is who is YouTube for and
I think this is something which I'd like
to get your feedback whines who should
be doing YouTube's content creation
because the people which I mentioned
previously myself felt it Franco and
Charlie McDonnell just three examples we
are individuals who make videos and
that's one noble part of YouTube's
addition the vlogging tradition but
companies have YouTube channels
universities have YouTube channels I
mean my college has a YouTube channel I
made it is that the purpose of YouTube
is that trying to take a format and and
try and meld the formats to that purpose
in other words are we kind of ruining
YouTube by as a format by expecting
corporations to work with it I get the
impression this is going to be yet
another very long video so sorry about
that hopefully by the time this is up
there live in a couple more videos
uploaded and after this there's probably
going to be a little gap and then I'll
have the view other videos up and ready
for you all possibly before that the
string theory video which I said I've
been making for ages but I want to get
it done really right so sorry about that
thank you for being patient thank you
for watching and I will see you next
time leave your thoughts in the comments
about who do you think you chose content
creation is meant to be for and I will
see you crazy